how are you Chris ah here corner lovely
to see you I love the way you say my
name
III get you know they say that thing
about I don't know if we talked about
this before but you know the way the
Irish accent has that reputation for
being romantic or something yeah if I
worked it out scientifically that it's
the elongation of the vowels because a
consonant gives a word its power yes a
vowel gives the word of feeling so the
longer those vowels are even engaged
that's what makes it sound all sexy like
elongated I love that it's as elongated
you know I grew up next door to these
twin brothers that were in probably
their sixties the Murphy boys and I was
a kid and I'd be out shoveling snow and
the Murphy boys would be out there
talking to each other and they were from
some small village in Ireland I couldn't
understand a word they were saying you
know people think it's the Lucky Charms
elf
oh I should be going it's not the real
thing when you hear it it's impossible
I never understood a word I think they
were both calling for help and I never
understood like Lassie
exactly how are you doing you're in your
house yeah quarantined how first of all
how's your wife is your wife handling
this well yes she lives in the otic now
run a week and a half ago I believe her
last words were I never want to see any
of you again good she's been she seems
happy I hear a lot of men's voices up
there seems to be she sends the odd text
yeah and that's great you know that
feels a little pick me up in the middle
of the day you know it's good I'm glad
that she's meeting other people and
she's in the attic and she's no it's
been brilliant actually the whole thing
I just because who knew that what we
needed was just more time together you
know like an endless infinity amount of
time I think
that we are operating at only 24 hours a
day so sad to me I just wish it was more
time just more time for more questions
and more time to notice little things
that each of you do that might be
annoying yes we need more of that you
know I know you're from you're from
Roscommon that's right and where is
Roscommon but it's kind of in the
northwest just east of Galway and me oh
very useful how is you must have family
there how are they doing with the virus
how are they with the quarantine is it
are they handling it well I think so I
mean my my mum and dad are still in my
hometown and Boyle and their cocooning
which is this thing that you were is law
so they can't leave the house if you're
over 70 Oh which is pretty full on yeah
um but my mother it seems to be dealing
really well with it she's a therapist so
she's been doing a lot of zoom perfectly
and things like that and then she's kind
of just waiting at home the rest of the
time waving out the window to paper I
like to think of her like this adorable
golden retriever seemed pretty good and
then my sister has five kids so she
varying ages so she and her husband are
just it's like a I might manic holiday
yeah okay you know it's I think in
Ireland there is this there's been tough
times before so in a way it's kind of
like a notch on the bedpost of our
collective historical failures I always
think the Irish expect things to be bad
you know yeah and so when there's a
global pandemic and it's the world seems
like it's going to [ __ ] the Irish are
like
well of course yes right we hope we did
have a feeling this was gonna happen
there's also we're here in California
which is a very different experience I
think in Ireland where we're like okay
so you can't go outside and you can't
really see each other and you know it's
kind of dangerous I think a lot of Irish
people were like oh you mean like winter
over here it's being a little kind of
different yeah yeah exactly yeah very
true very and we're ready for it